hello and welcome to this video playing
I am light like Martin Susan devour oh I
have a disasterous score zero wins for
losses three draws it that does not look
good really absolutely have to study a
new line they're always plate this plate
this CD five early which doesn't seem to
be that grade okay he seems to know
stuff here that's not fair I know
nothing
stooping out of that you five I do
hmm I have absolutely no idea Bishop d3
maybe let's just develop stuff
okay glad that I could cancel even if
what doesn't clear that and this was
necessarily possible but now he he has
to slowly but surely think about stuff
like 95 or B form okay so Bishop f5 91
bishop age seven this is interesting so
I mean okay ever heaven absolutely
atrocious Kauai against him so let's try
something something interesting okay
let's not pre mafia let's think for a
moment i also have before let's say king
of eight as before this is this is this
is a move before why not actually there
is no reason why not actually i can't i
can do that right before and let's do it
what does he have some miracle move now
93 or something now i don't think so FK
this is this is too dangerous this
attack will be too dangerous f takes
Bishop takes King in the corner the
ephod is open you know this is not I
don't think this will go Billy will be
holding nitrogen
I don't believe in it check that is
winning a tech mr. light like I don't
believe it so what should unite h4 is
the first thing that looks very
dangerous threatening made
okay let's do it
okay I'm curious to see the move now
yeah this 196 probably just can you get
home bishop just 6 30 6 is that really
defending night 5 is also move just
taking this threatening to take and play
Quincy five anyway I cannot spend a
whole time here it doesn't look like
right I'm 95 maybe I don't know Queen g5
does he really defend this crap it
amazing 25 maybe 25
okay night at five was probably also was
probably wrong I don't know okay Bishop
here maybe
97 now I'm not thinking about this
anymore check
Queen h5 was my idea Queen age six lets
queen of eight so this one will be
Bishop f5
we'll see a defensive
how the text should be should be winning
Queen g6 Bishop f6 on or not this one I
wonder then bishop g6 time morning the
added winsome check that's also gave six
it's too much rook f6 Queen f7 made too
many things ya think so check black
resigns yeah I don't know it looked very
dangerous jam the opening the thing with
his opening is my the line that I
learned like a long long time ago was
this one but it really doesn't give
white much anymore back in the day they
thought that this might be a little
something for why but I've never updated
this is for real anthem this is the
modern main line but I just don't know
it well 92 is probably right to him
anyway that this looked fairly fairly
normal okay Bishop d3 engine want
students to take him not to move that s
all of course yeah looks very good I
have interested in the attack if that
was really working or not you the engine
likes this the chalice I but now wants
to take on d1 yeah that was the simple
move and as this was what I originally
wanted to do and thought this should be
also good the beef before is still is
there's a threat and after this for
example I thought Queen to f5 on this
engine giving him a slight advantage
whatever that means in a position like
this now I've ideas like this move the
bishop and look at the king but okay I
went before which is the most aggressive
okay to kill me three that's Jess king
edge
and now a queen move Queen to d8 and now
now the engine gives me a wind with b5
there is a logic to that move right so
be five if the night moves and well not
quite sure where it should go then have
95 for example sometime think something
like that 95 should win and b5 makes
lots of sense maybe this was wrong in
yeah it is wrong objectively wrong
rookie 6 was the good defense and now
the engine things black is better now to
Knight a5 chip back Irene normal move
Bishop g5 is given by the computer and
now I went here and f6 losses due to not
just having he has to go queen to d7 and
here black should win oh k minus 1 is
what the engine is giving and I might
have been exchanging the pawn down
yeah it's dangerous it's still dangerous
for him but objectively it shouldn't be
enough this is what the engine is giving
a no this funny move for bishop here
yeah no no that's really over I hope I
played it correctly Queen h5 is correct
threatening first of all this just just
take the rook now and this is right it
does not have a defense that I also have
this at the bishop is covering this ok 5
jan this is no made in three yeah so I
was a bit lucky that he went to f6 here
right so if he plays screen to d7 he
probably would have maintained a good
run against me even though it is not a
practically simple position I mean if we
also this this could happen I mean all
my pieces are attacking and this is
always difficult to play but objectively
um yeah blackest black is better here of
course ok thanks for watching